what I'm trying to work out the memory
is the area of this sector I know the
area of the circle that's the easy bit
this pot takes a little work so what I
want to do is say will be area of the
sector the area of the sector is clearly
related to the length of the arc okay
like do you see the longer the arc
becomes if the arc went all the way
around it would make the whole circle
and as I make that are shorter the area
would also get smaller do you agree with
that okay so these guys are related to
each other I'm gonna connect those two
to other values that I need to work out
okay the area of the side length of the
arc here it's part of the big
circumference remember I told you there
are two sir conferences so I'm gonna
talk about big one and a little one
that's this all the way around so as if
I have a whole circle there hmm we'll
carefully the diagram what is this big
circumference we'll look at it the angle
is gonna be 360 degrees all the way
around but if I want the link it's going
to be two times in pi times this radius
in here right I know it's not cold R but
that's cuz I already used that lever
okay so it's going to be this
circumference all the way around right I
suppose I should collect these
now if I compare these two if I went all
the way around got the whole
circumference this sector remember I
said it wouldn't just be like part of a
circle it would be the whole circle do
you agree with that okay so have a look
here area an area length and like
because we're talking about the same
shapes when you compare these they're
equal okay we're comparing part of the
area the whole area part of the
circumference the whole circumference
okay I'm ready to fill this in the area
is sector I don't know that's the whole
thing I'm trying to work out so I'm just
gonna write area or sector but I can
work out every other thing here 1 2 3 ok
I already taught me the length of the
arc do you see it on the board what's
the length of the arc to pay off right
what about the circumference including
this bit that's not here it's got it
still circled but it's a different
radius what's the radius of this circle
over here it's L is a decent right there
that's this is the radius of this circle
over here not this one it's this one so
it's 2 pi times the radius is just a
different label okay you following me so
far now when I look at the whole circle
that big one over here but the area of
the big circle it's gonna be a be
careful in its pi times the radius
squared but my radius over here is L so
therefore I'm gonna write PI L Swit now
I'm almost there I'm so very close let's
simplify leave it have a look at the
right-hand side that fraction I can
write in an ADA way right what can I
cancel on the top and the bottom
g'bye it's up there it's up there it's
gone so I'm just gonna it's
to indicate I'm gonna cancel them in a
second yeah what what am I trying to
find what's the thing I'm trying to
solve forward
it's the scepter right so you see it's
there I don't want this stuff hanging
around the bottom I kind of want to get
rid of it over here so I'm gonna
multiply both sides by PI L square all
right then yeah
x squared Swit just see what's gonna
happen have a look on the left-hand side
what's the what's the benefit of
multiplying by PI L square the the
benefit is I get the area of a sector by
itself because look this cancels with
this so I've just got the area of the
sector as soon as I work out what's
happening over here on the right have a
look I can cancel some more stuff right
what can I cancel there's an L on the
bottom there's a there's two of them on
the top okay so if this one goes
how many else am I left with in the
numerator just one so that disappeared
have a look okay we've done all the hard
work on the left hand side all I get
left with is the area of a sector that's
all that's left on the left hand side
everything else is canceled have a look
at the right hand side what's left on
the denominator I think I've canceled
everything on the denominator have
another here that chip I went with that
to PI what about this guy it's going
because of one of these elves right so
there is nothing left on the denominator
look at the numerator I see it ah and a
pie and a single L do you agree with me
yeah you follow me so I'm gonna write it
like this because we usually put pies
out the front
need to descend so we're done that was
it
I know there was a lot of work but the
whole point of being able to create that
in front of you so you could see where
all those legs come from now I can
actually say what the steps are you
think we know what the base is all you
need to do is add into the curvy pot and
there is the surface area on the curve
PI R squared plus PI L I reminds me bit
of a little bit of cylinder German
cylinder from memory I think the
cylinder was this I think that was the
cylinder do you remember that this is
the top of the bottom and this is the
round bead do you remember that no the
curvy part that goes around it's the
same here saying if there's no top in
bottom of it's just a bottom and then
here's the relevant I thought then give
me a like
correct so if you know what this angle
is here that's another way to work out
the area of sector however you generally
don't get given that you generally you
give them legs rather than available
okay all right now that was challenging
which is why the next bit I'm not going
to expect you to do all the legwork for
it the heading says steps area codes and
spheres right so I'm just gonna give you
this result not gonna ask you to prove
it because it's actually super hard but
unfortunately got a bit too beat up so
that's the last time I made it but this
is a roughly spherical object okay now
if you look really closely I'll stop
moving it now do you see what the net is
made of can you actually see what it's
made of
okay so what I did was and you may want
to just draw one of these what it's made
of is something called a cool this shape
is called a Gore it's kind of like a
sliver and I took a whole bunch of them
I curved them around as best as I could
and I ended up with this okay I know
it's not beautiful but it works okay now
here's the lovely thing about this
sphere if you were to take all of the
gauze and cut them all out what you
would find is that the surface area of a
sphere is equal to okay have a look a
sphere just has a radius right like a
radius like that from the middle out to
any of the parts on the surface if you
take that radius and you just pop it
into this four squared that's it it's
remarkably simple now I don't expect you
to completely take my word for it so one
day and I did exactly that
if you cut out all of these
right I think I had nine of them in the
end okay and you reassemble them you get
one two three four circles every circle
has an area off I'll sweat so pull pass
wet okay now like I said this is quite
time-consuming so that's why I'm not
asking you to do it right now but that
result will help you as you work through
the remained all exercise that I have
assigned okay so just to tie it up in a
new polar surface area of a curve PI R
squared plus PI RL surface area of
sphere four PI R squared will stop
that's in okay